- There are always gems to discover
when you scroll through social media
and I bring you the best, hopefully.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
It's something most of us
probably don't even think about,
but there are too many kids
who lack one of the most
basic needs: underwear.
And for kids it can be mortifying.
And that's why one Houston
woman has led the charge
to get drawers to children in need.
We have her on the line right now
watching on Fox 26 Houston.
From Undies For everyone,
everybody say hello to Amy.
What's up, Amy?
(audience cheering)
- Hi, everybody.
- Hi.
So like I said
this isn't something
many people think about.
So how did you discover this need?
- It was in 2008 and a
social worker told me
about kids who got things donated to them
like clothes and backpacks,
but nobody gave underwear.
And so, I created Undies For Everyone
to address this basic need.
We just feel like this is something
that has a big impact at school.
It affects the kids'
confidence and self-esteem.
We don't want them to miss a day
of what they can learn at school.
We don't want them to be
embarrassed or be bullied.
School really leads kids to
success and we know that.
So underwear is a basic dignity
that a lot of us take for granted,
but really everyone deserves.
- Absolutely, and you also make sure
that even how they're
distributed is dignified, right?
- Yes, we never see the kids.
We never follow up with the kids.
We send them out through,
every school district
has a homeless department
and through Boys and Girls
Club, Child Protective Services,
pediatric mobile clinics,
and we have a whole army of volunteers
who roll and pack the underwear for us.
Every kid gets seven pairs
of underwear, a full week.
And to date, we've given away
5 million pair of underwear,
and next year alone we'll
give away 1.6 million pairs.
(audience cheering)
- Wow.
Well thank you so much, Amy.
That's incredible.
It's something we don't think about
but is such a necessity.
So thank you so much.
I'm liking your post right now, all right.
(audience cheering)
And that's not all.
That's not all, girl.
Our season long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of The Kelly Clarkson Show
want to honor truly unstoppable
people just like yourself.
So they're gonna give
Undies For Everyone $1,000
to help out.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you so much.
That's amazing.
- Absolutely.
Thank you so much, Amy,
for joining us today.
And thank you to all our guests,
Zoey Deutch, Mike Rowe,
Jeannie Mai Jenkins,
Tyree Glasgow, Officer
Kim Erica Francis Wang,
Sheila Watco, and all of our
friends at NBC 10 Philadelphia.
Y'all have a great day and if
it's not, try and change it.